We've talked about loading data from flat files by way of CSV, but a lot of the
time, the data that data scientists work with
are stored in relational databases. A relational database is
similar to a collection of spreadsheets. In each
spreadsheet, there are columns and rows. A column specifies
a value and its type such as player ID
or team ID or record. Each row contains values
for each column such as 1 or 1 or
245-150. Or 1 and Yankees, things like that. In
the database world, we call each set of rows
and columns a table rather than a spreadsheet. And the
tables are usually related to each other in some
way. It's very important to be somewhat familiar with relational
databases. Since they're used in so many places and
also since we'll be storing some of the data required
for our class project in a small database. Let's take some time and talk
briefly about how one can store and
retrieve data from relational databases. In this
course, we won't discuss the design of
databases. Topics like normalization, indices, keys, things
like that. Some of these topics will be covered in Data Wrangling with Mongo DB.